KORY JEFFREY:
Welcome, everybody.
We are on site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
Joining me in this
video today is
Tim Draper, founder of
Draper University, DFJ,
and Draper Associates.
Thank you for joining me.
TIM DRAPER: Terrific.
Thanks for having me.
KORY JEFFREY: So let's start
with Draper University.
What was the impetus to
start the university?
TIM DRAPER: So I started
Draper University,
because in 2008, the financial
world was collapsing.
And I was looking for heroes.
And I was thinking, wait,
where are the heroes?
And I thought, the
world needs more heroes.
And heroes can come in any form.
They can come as
revolutionaries,
as entrepreneurs, as artists.
But the thinking was that I
could actually help with that.
And so I started a
school to train heroes.
And people go in
for about six weeks.
And it's totally immersive.
And they come out.
And they have this incredible
enthusiasm and gusto
for whatever it
is they're doing.
And I think we've accomplished
that goal in some ways.
I think the school is working.
KORY JEFFREY: And so could we
talk a little bit about impact?
Because just earlier today,
I had two of your alumni,
I suppose, in the chair.
So obviously, very
prominent in the ecosystem.
Have you seen a lot of
success stories come out?
TIM DRAPER: Yeah.
We've had about 500
students that have come.
They come from about
60 different countries.
KORY JEFFREY: Wow.
TIM DRAPER: And they've
started about 220 companies.
And some of those
companies now have built--
some have gone out of business.
Some have built kind of
nice bases of support.
And I think what they
learn at Draper University
a lot is persistence.
They keep at it,
and they keep at it,
and they keep tweaking
their business.
And eventually, great
things are going to happen.
And I think that's
been the case.
And there are probably
10 real standouts
that look like they have
the potential to be unicorns
or whatever.
Yeah.
KORY JEFFREY: And so
is this all tech focus?
Or is it just a process of
entrepreneurship that kind of--
TIM DRAPER: It's a process
of entrepreneurship.
But most of the students that
come to Draper University
are focused on
technology in some way
as it will transform an
industry, something like that.
KORY JEFFREY: OK.
And so in the university
space in the world,
do you see this as a disruptive
model for a certain segment
of how to do entrepreneurship?
Are you going head to
head with universities?
How do you see
yourself in that space?
TIM DRAPER: Well, I think
we're fitting in well
with universities.
We're only six to eight weeks.
So Stanford has given
some students credit
to come to Draper University.
We have a whole program with
San Luis Obispo Cal Poly.
They come.
A group of them come
to Draper University
at one of our sessions.
And so I think
we're playing nice.
And it ends up working out quite
well for those universities.
We can be their
entrepreneur program.
And we really do know
how to train heroes.
So people are enjoying it.
As to the first part
of your question,
yes, we are looking for new ways
to transform, and accelerate
people, and get them
to where they're going
in a faster and better way.
And the school also
is a lead-in to people
who might want to
go to the Boost
accelerator, boost.vc
accelerator, or to Hero City,
or get funded by
Draper Associates.
It's sort of a
natural progression.
KORY JEFFREY: Right.
TIM DRAPER: And it
may be a new way
of educating, at least for
these extraordinary individuals.
KORY JEFFREY: Sure.
So bringing people in and
then finding the ramp for them
to continue to be successful.
TIM DRAPER: Yeah.
KORY JEFFREY: Interesting.
So have you made investments
from Draper Associates
into entrepreneurs
in the school?
TIM DRAPER: Oh, yeah.
And quite a few Draper
University students
have gotten Draper
Associates money.
They pay tuition to
go, but some of them
end up getting an
awful lot more back.
KORY JEFFREY: [LAUGHS]
TIM DRAPER: --when they
build their businesses.
KORY JEFFREY: Sure.
TIM DRAPER: And
hopefully, I'll end up
getting even more back
after that. [LAUGHS]
KORY JEFFREY: After that.
Right.
So when your investing,
what's the investment thesis
of Draper Associates?
What are you looking for?
TIM DRAPER: So I'm looking
for things that really
will transform industries.
Industries occasionally
get to the point
where they're oligopolies
and they're dominated
by just 2 or 3 or 10 companies.
And when you know you've got
an oligopoly or a monopoly
is when you know the service
isn't as good as it used to be
and the price keeps going up.
And so I'm always
looking for opportunities
where that price-to-service
ratio has expanded
and there's an
opportunity for a startup
to serve that population better
than they're being served now.
KORY JEFFREY: Excellent.
That's interesting.
So I guess my next question
would be, obviously, you
get quite a large
breadth of-- looks
at different types of
technologies, people pitching
you all the time.
Is there a certain
technology space
that's really interesting
for you right now,
something that gets you excited?
TIM DRAPER: Yeah.
I'm really interested in these
industries that haven't yet
been transformed, where
over the last 15, 20 years,
you've seen information,
communications, entertainment,
music, taxis all transformed.
In the future, I can see
finance, banking transform.
Education, I think,
is on its way
to getting some sort
of transformation.
Medical technologies are coming
along that are more data-based
than doctor-to-patient-based.
And that could end up
being a real transformation
in health care.
And then I think governments are
going through a transformation
now.
We had the prime
minister of Estonia come
to Draper University and speak.
And he said, just by
instituting digital signatures,
I saved 2% of the GDP.
And so it made me think that,
hey, maybe these governments
are looking for
entrepreneurs to kind of help
them better serve
their citizens.
And he also said that just by
instituting digital voting,
all the young people
started to vote.
And digital identity has
improved their business
climate, but it's also
lowered their crime rate.
So interesting
things are happening
in government technology.
And I'm looking for
those companies, too.
KORY JEFFREY: Oh, that's
really fascinating.
TIM DRAPER: Yeah.
KORY JEFFREY: So you
clearly get pitched a lot.
Obviously, even
just coming here,
there was a lineup
of people walking
behind you trying to pitch you.
What are the things
that you look
for in somebody that makes you
receptive to hearing a pitch?
What are the things
that you don't like?
What's the best way to
get in touch with you?
TIM DRAPER: I think the
best way to connect with me
is through your initial idea.
Is it transformative?
Does it pass my 15-year test.
My 15-year test is in 15 years,
is this a possibility or is it
sort of going to come and
go in the next six months
by something that
improves on it?
And so if you're really
thinking 15 years out, I mean,
we're going to
have self-driving,
flying cars in 15 years.
So does your plan
relate to that?
Or are we going to have drone
delivery on anticipated needs?
Where before you even know your
blood glucose level is low,
a drone shows up with a taco.
So in that world, does
your business make sense?
And that's kind of what
we're really looking for.
And then I would want to
know how well versed are you
on that industry?
And how do you know
your competition?
And do you have a rational
approach at your business?
And is the business model
one where the customers
become the sales force?
So that'll help.
KORY JEFFREY: That'll help.
So a lot of what you just
painted-- self-driving cars,
glucose levels, drone
deliveries, this
is the Google
channel-- a lot of that
is stuff that we're
publicly working on.
Is there anything at Google
that makes you excited?
Is there any favorite Google
technology or anything
that you think is interesting?
TIM DRAPER: You know, I like
all those interesting ideas that
come out of the
Google's 20% rule, where
they-- engineers have 20% to
go do the thing that they like,
they want to do themselves.
Because those are the
things that are on the edge.
And engineers are kind of
looking for things that
are more exciting to work on.
And those edge
products are really
what the engineers
are really into.
And I think when an engineer's
really into something,
it's usually novel
enough for me to want
to be interested in it, too.
So if you're a part of the
Google Developers community,
you're probably developing
something pretty interesting
that you love that's not just
the 20%, but your whole 100%
is focused on
something you love.
And in that case,
I think if you've
got any kind of a
futuristic approach at all,
I think I'd be
interested in hearing
what it is you're working on.
KORY JEFFREY: Very cool.
Well, thank you very
much for joining us, Tim.
TIM DRAPER: Good.
My pleasure.
KORY JEFFREY: Thank you
guys for joining us at home.
We are on site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]